>> Tucker: WELL, WHATEVER ELSE
YOU SAY ABOUT THE LEFT, THEY ARE
NOT LIKE THE RIGHT.
THEY JUST DO IT, RIGHT OR WRONG
AND THEY MOVE QUICK.
LAST YEAR THE LEFT TARGETED THE
CONFEDERATE STATUES FOR
DEMOLITION.
AND THEY DETRIED THEM WITH MOB
VIOLENCE AND GOT AWAY AND NOW
THEY PICKED A NEW TARGET AND
A STATUE THAT OFFENDS ANYBODY IN
A STATUE'VE PRESIDENT WILLIAM
MCKINLEY ON GROUNDS HE PURSUED
POLICIES OFFENSIVE TO NATIVE
AMERICANS.
AND WE HAVE PAUL HERE TONIGHT
WHO VOTED FOR THE REMOVAL.
THANK YOU FOR COMING DOWN.
OF ALL OF THE STATUES THAT YOU
TEAR DOWN WHY MCKINLEY?
>> IT IS THE ONLY ONE WE GOT.
>> Tucker: GOOD ANSWER.
AND HERE YOU HAVE A GUY THAT
JOINED THE UNION ARMY AT 18 AND
FOUGHT THE CONFEDERACY AND SPENT
YEARS IN BATTLE.
I DON'T THINK HE HAS
A REPUTATION OF A CRUEL GUY AND
HE WAS A VICTIM MUCH GUN
VIOLENCE AND WHY ARE YOU PICKING
ON HIM?
>> I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT ALL OF
THE STUFF ABOUT HIM.
YOU MENTIONED A COUPLE OF
THINGS, BUT THERE IS TONS WAS
OTHER STUFF ABOUT THE GUY AND
WHEN YOU TALK THE TOTALITY OF
EVERYTHING HE WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR AND WHAT HAPPENED IN HIS
PRESIDENCY.
YOU LOOK AT IT.
POSITIVE AND NEGATIVE.
IF I WAS OFFERED THAT STATUE AS
A CITY COUNCILMAN I WOULD SAY NO
THANK YOU.
I AM BASICALLY CORRECT BEING
A 125-YEAR-OLD ERROR OF
JUDGMENT.
>> Tucker: YOU DIDN'T PUT THE
STATUE THERE AND ARE YOU HAVING
A TOWN WIDE VOTE ON THIS?
>> THE CITY COUNCIL 112 YEARS
AGO DECIDED TO PUT IT THERE AND
THE CITY COUNCIL HAS THE POWER
TO REMOVE THIS.
AND IF THE CITIZENS DON'T WANT
IT TO HAPPEN, WE HAVE REFERUNDUM
INITIATE ITCH THAT HAPPENS IN
DALLAS THAT HAPPENS CONSTANTLY
AND IT CANA BE A THOUSAND
SIGNATURES AND ON THE BALLOT.
>> Tucker: WHY NOT LET THEM DO
THAT ANYWAY.
SAY THERE IS A PAUL PITOINO
STATUE AND I HOPE THERE NEVER
IS.
BUT HOW WOULD YOU LIKE IT IS,
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE
ASSESSED ON EVERYTHING.
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE IT IF PEOPLE
SAY TEAR THE STATUE DOWN AND HE
WAS FLAWED.
AND SHOULDN'T WE BE MORE DPOF
GIVEN.
>> WE ARE ALL EQUAL AND DON'T
DESERVE A STATUE.
I THINK IT IS A MISTAKE TO PUT
STATUES UP IN HUMAN.
STATUE OF LIBERTY IS NOT A HUMAN
OR A STYLIZED PERSON AND WHEN
YOU PUT UP A HUMAN, YOU ARE
ALWAYS GOING TO HAVE A PROBLEM.
WHETHER MISSIONOLINI.
A PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE KIND OF
WINNING ME OVER WITH THAT
ARGUMENT AND I THINK WE
SHOULDN'T WORSHIP THE
POLITICIANS AND SO I KIND OF
AGREEMENT I WANT SURE WE DON'T
AGREE ON ANYTHING OTHER THAN
THAT THAT.
I THINK IT IS A ISLAMIC POINT
AND STILL A PRETTY GOOD POINT.
SINCE HIS STATUE IS UP THERE,
AND NO ONE LIVING MADE THE
DECISION TO PUT IT THERE.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A AN
AFFIRMATIVE DECISION TO PUT IT.
ARE YOU NOT SAYING HIS SINS WERE
OUT WEIGHED.
AND HE FOUGHT AGAINST SLAVERY
AND BY THE WAY, HE WAS A VICTIM
MUCH GUN VIOLENCE.
SHOULDN'T THAT GIVE HIM A PASS?
>> YOU KNOW, I TOTALLY SEE THE
GOD POINTS AND I SEE THE BAD
POINTS AND I AS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL.
AND A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE TOWN, I HAVE TO
SAY GO DEEP INSIDE AND WHAT
THIS ANY OTHER TIME?
AND 13 YEARS AGO, IT CAME BEFORE
US BEFORE AND WE DIDN'T HAVE
A MAJORITY AND SO IT STAYED.
THIS TIME 13 YEARS LATER, IT
CAME UP AGAIN, AND WE HAD
A MAJORITY AND SO, OUR MAJORITY
FOR IT TO LEAVE.
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU SOCHLED ALL
OF THE PROBLEMS IN YOUR TOWN AND
LIKE LITERALLY A UTOPPIA.
>> HEY, LOOK.
NO BODY SOCHLS ALL OF THE
PROBLEMS.
>> YOU HAVE NO CRIMES AND NO ONE
DOUBLE PARKED OR DIVORCED OR
LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
NO ONE CHOSES MICROWAVES
BURRITOS OVER BRUSSEL SPROUTS
AND SO IN THE SPARE TIME YOU
TEAR DOWN MCKINLEY STATUES, IS
THAT WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> NO, THAT IS AN OPINION.
AS A CITY COUNCILMAN.
I HAVE TO COVER EVERYTHING.
IT HAS COME TO US BEFORE.
AND IT CAME BEFORE I EVEN LIVED
HERE AND THIS ISSUE AND IT IS
LIKE OKAY, STOP WASTING TIME.
I AM WILLING TO TAKE THE FREIGHT
AND MAKE THE DECISION TO MAKE
THAT MOTION TO MOVE THAT THING
SO THAT WE CAN BE DONE WITH IT
AND MOVE ON AND NOT WASTE ANY
MORE TIME.
SO YEAH, I REALLY DON'T LIKE
WASTING TIME ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: I DISAGREE WITH YOU.
BUT YOU MAKE A GOOD POINT ABOUT
NOT WOR STHPING PEOPLE.
I AM WITH YOU ON THAT.
COUNCILMAN.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: JASON NICOLE SYSTEM
A PROFESSOR AND COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: UNLESS YOU AGREE WITH
THE PROFESSOR WHO I THINK HAS
A GOOD POINT.
WE SHOULDN'T NAME THINGS ABOUT
LIVING POLITICIAN.
WHETHER KENNEDY KILLED A WOMAN
OR ROBERT BIRD.
OR ANY POLITICIANS.
I STRONGLY AGREE WITH THAT.
BUT MCKINLEY.
WHY IS HE SO SINFUL?
>> IF BEE LOOK AT HIS HISTORY.
HE DID THINGS IN TERMS OF THE
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE AND GIVING
THEIR LAND TO WHITE SETTLELER
AND BREAKING UP THEIR A UTOMNY.
AND HE HAS ISSUES IN HIS PAST.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT FOR US AND IT IS
INTERESTING THIS DISCUSSION.
I AM GOING TO PLAY THE
REPUBLICAN HERE AND SAY THAT YOU
HAD A CITY COUNCIL, A LOCAL
GROUP WHO MADE A DECISION FOR
THEIR COMMUNITY, THAT'S WHAT
THEY ARE ELECTED TO DO.
AND YET YOU AND I HERE IN
WASHINGTON IN OUR SHIRT AND TIES
IS TESTIFYING THEM WHAT THEY DID
WAS WRONG.
>> Tucker: I FEEL FULLY
EMPOWERED TO PASS DECISIONS ON
WHAT GOVERNMENTS MAKE.
>> YOU HAVE NO.
>> Tucker: I DO.
AND JUST BECAUSE A GOVERNMENT IS
SMALL DOESN'T MEAN IT DOESN'T
MAKE TERRIBLE DECISION.
I AM NOT THAT KIND OF
CONSERVATIVE.
AND A LOT OF TYRANNY ON CITY
COUNCILS.
I HAVE SEEN IT LIVING IN A SMALL
TOWN.
WE ARE RETROACTIVELY JUDGING
PEOPLE SELECTIVELY.
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
A MONUMENT FOR THE CHEROKEES AND
THEY BROUGHT THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN SLAVES.
I AM NOT ATTACKING THE
CHEROKEES, HISTORY IS MORE
COMPLICATED THAN WE PRETEND IT
IS.
AND YOU KNOW THAT AS
A PROFESSOR.
AND WHY DO WE KNOWLEDGE IT IS
BLACK AND WHITE AND GOOD AND BAD
PEOPLE.
>> WE TALK ABOUT PRESIDENTS, WE
NEED A DIALOGUE ABOUT THE
TOTALITY OF WHAT THEY HAVE DONE.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE, AND THE
MOST IMPORTANT POINT TO ME, IS
THAT ACTIVIST SAY THEY WILL
RAISE $65,000 TO REMOVE THE
STATUE.
IT IS NOT A BURDEN ON THE
TAXPAYERS AND HOUSED SOMEWHERE.
THEY HAVE A VETERAN'S PLACE.
>> Tucker: IT IS CLASSIC RED
GUARD NONSENSE AND DESTROY THE
PAST AND THINKING THAT WILL
CREATE A FUTURE.
>> THAT IS NOT DESTRUCTION.
PAST.
YOUR PAST STILL XICHT AND THEY
WILL -- EXIST.
>> Tucker: NO ONE IS OFFENDED BY
THIS.
>> THERE IS A NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY 20 MINUTES SOUTH OF
ARCATA DON'T LIKE TO SEE THE
STATUE.
>> Tucker: I WILL TALK TO ONE OF
THEM.
BUT TAKING DOWN A STATUE DOES
NOT IMPROVE THEIR LIVES OF THE
COMMUNITY.
WHY DO WE HAVE A FDR MEMORIAL
AND HE PUT IN INTERNMENT CAMPS.
>> IN LIVING MEMORY.
SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE STILL A
LIVE.
IT WAS LIKE 80 YEARS AGO.
>> I THINK YOU ARE TRYING TO
MAKE AN ARGUMENT THAT I AM NOT
MAKING AND YOU ARE TRYING TO
DEBATE ME WITH SOMETHING ON
A POINT I AM NOT MAKING.